[Musique]
nos envoyés spéciaux se sont aventurés
dans cette région que les cartes désigne
sous le nom de xvième arrondissement de
paris mais qu'on nomme ici en toute
simplicité
le 16e tournant le dos à la tour d'un
certain effet le nos reporters ont cru
déceler chez les autochtones une
tendance prononcée à se déplacer en
groupe
quant à la population féminine elle a
mené particulièrement apte à porter des
lunettes de soleil dès l'âge de 13 ans
elle est toujours surélevée elle est en
outre doué d'un langage particulièrement
articulé oui je n'ai dans ce lien
pourquoi le 16e ce n'est peut-être que
770 hectares mai 770 hectares compris
entre un fleuve appelé scène
une porte monumentale nommé arc de
l'étoile et surtout surtout une
plantation d'arbres si réputé qu'on se
contente de l'appeler le boire tout
simplement
on y assiste aujourd'hui à la langue
disparition de vastes demeures où vivait
des tribus de quatre à cinq personnes au
profit d'une forme d'habitat groupé cet
agent parfois sur 20 étages c'est une
région riche bien qu'on y travaille
rarement le revenu moyen annuel a été
évalué par tête enfants et nonagénaires
compris à un million cinq cent mille
francs fait la région de france où l'on
trouve le plus long taux de vison bias
et le plus de jaguar
et le plus de but fait de toutes les
sortes d'ailleurs comme le plus de taken
on note dans cette région une forte
immigration étrangères évaluées à
quelques 90 mille personnes les femmes
de chambre tout en espagnol les nurses
suisse et les chauffeurs des batignolles
forte proportion de notabilité c'est là
qu'on trouve le plus d'académiciens et
d'ambassadeur c'est aussi là qu'on
trouve le maximum de prénom est le plus
de particules la conservation de la race
est ici bien assurée on peut avancer car
âge égal âge égal à l'enfant du 16e
mesure un centimètre de plus qu'à la fin
du xvème des établissements spécialisés
et privés s'occupent de leur donner une
éducation de choix qui trouve son
prolongement naturel entre les murs du
lycée janson de sailly et l'on peut dire
pour conclure qu'il n'est pas un
habitant du 16e que l'idée d'exil
puis ce même effleuré il n'est pas
concevoir qu'on puisse vivre ailleurs
qu'ici il est certain que si le 16e
n'est pas tout paris on peut dire que
c'est le tout paris assume
[Musique]